[Applause]
all right
um this weekend i watched the social
dilemma okay i'll cost you did not watch
the social dilemma
um alex you saw it yeah mark you see it
yep taylor have you seen the social
dilemma
you should watch it everybody at home
it's on netflix very interesting
uh fatalist look at um
social media social media platforms and
their like manipulation of like the
human psyche to force you
into you know spending hours and hours
of your time watching social media
and the role they play in the
divisiveness
uh in our country right now and fake
news etc and it's got this like horrible
approach to social media
and i cannot sit here and hate on this
documentary alex because that same
algorithm that they're trashing is the
reason why
i have a career it's the reason why we
have this studio
it's the reason why people are watching
this right now
so the algorithm they're looking at this
algorithm like all it does is feed you
this horrible [ __ ] and like what yeah
your worst possible nightwear and feed
into your fears and
there's nothing fact check and yes of
course it's all right but at the same
time like
and they're they're making all these
points about like all you're doing is um
spending hours upon hours on the
internet right all day you're wasting
your time it's like
yeah we can do that because the internet
has made our lives so easy
that's a good point we can look at our
phone for four hours because i don't
have to
go to the store to pick up groceries i
just type it in my phone and then they
bring it to me
right i don't have to wait online at a
movie theater i just watch it
on home on netflix i don't have to do
anything i don't even have to
for places like reservations and all
this kind of stuff i guess you can call
up and make reservations back in the day
but it's just so simple to do absolutely
everything we have tons of extra time
just staring at our phone
now i'm not saying we should okay but
the last thing you're going to see is me
come out a content creator and podcaster
and tell people
not to look at their phones can i say
this the one thing i did see the guy's
name
stop talking watch the [ __ ]
documentary
stop your [ __ ] talking
the guy's name tristan yeah when he
corrects the [ __ ] who says tristan he's
like tristan thank you oh yeah yeah
that was good [ __ ] that guy yeah through
and through nothing you say is valid and
also it kind of feels like a bunch of
people got fired from these social media
platforms they're now like
social media is bad like it's literally
all the guys that made social media so
bad
now going oh by the way it's bad yeah by
the way i'm not making any money off of
it anymore so i just want to let you
know it's bad
from their mansion from their [ __ ]
mansion so let me find a way to make
money off of how it's bad dude it's the
confessions and economic hit man yeah
exactly right they're the guy who
literally worked for america
destabilizing third world countries so
we could take advantage of them
stop doing it and then wrote a book
about how [ __ ] up it was
the guy who wrote the book the game
remember that guy's name is neil strauss
the nerd to learn how to get [ __ ] he
wrote a book about it great read
okay you know what he did he got a girl
and he wrote another book
about how important it is not to just
[ __ ] random [ __ ] and get a girlfriend
these [ __ ] are literally giving
you aids
and then giving you the cure yes you're
afraid
say again no cure for aids but you know
what i mean like it's like don't be a
part of the problem and then act like
you're part of the solution and want
some pats on the [ __ ] back but now
what do you do though so if you are part
of the problem what's the solution
if you are part of the problem and you
don't stop yourself
like you get stopped the company's like
yo you're not really good at this [ __ ]
no more
peace then you're bitching about it get
out of here
but if you realize what you're creating
and then you go i don't feel like i want
to be part of this and then you take
every action you possibly can to like
fix it within the company and then they
fire you
then come back well one of the dudes was
about that
which one like the one that he's like
actually
holding conferences that's that tristan
and he sent that memo out while he was
still working at the company like yo
this is
becoming a problem right what's the
thing it is a problem
but here's the thing it is a problem but
it's also
we have to understand we are the problem
like i hate this zero accountability on
like humans part
right it's like you choose to watch the
video yeah like you have to be able to
discern between content
and that's something that like older
generations don't know how to do as well
as younger generations like
i was asking mark right i'm like yo when
you see a video randomly
like what's going on you see a picture
you see anything like that do you have
some healthy skepticism
about it and he goes oh yeah of course
like because i know how much fake should
exist there like my whole life i grew up
with people had like filters and all
this other stuff
if i show my girlfriend or you show your
girlfriend a picture of a beautiful
woman what's the first thing she does
trash him and start to tell you what's
what's fake
yeah so the younger generation is
observing content through the lens of
man this is [ __ ] up this ain't real
this is conspiracy this [ __ ]
the older generation the boomers are
consuming content on facebook all of our
parents are on facebook consuming
content like oh my god the world's on
fire everything's
going wrong this is horrible because
they grew up trusting
everything they saw so i don't know if
this is that much of a problem for kids
i know they're like suicides are up and
this that the other
and it's just like i don't know maybe
people weren't suicidal
that much back in the day really like i
don't know what to tell you suicides are
up by how much
quite a bit it was up quite a bit but
there's nothing else it does do too
i mean it was only since like
2010 when like social media really blew
up
hmm oh you know what's probably due to
the fact that there's way more ways to
commit suicide
you can't commit no suicide back in the
day would you be what do you think
when do you think pills were invented
pills came out like
[Laughter]
i 93. they came out with the it was all
yeah it was flintstone gummies and then
it was
some gummies they had the fire air maxes
right yeah and then they came out with
the pills and then you get od on the
pills
right about the jordan nines yeah it was
when the jordan knights came out they
came out with them pills
so now in all seriousness obviously
there's negative side i'm not acting
like there's no side effects the same
thing with like um
environmentalism you know what i'm
saying where it's like
yes of course we should care about the
environment but the fateless attitude
towards the environment like oh my god
we have 10 more years left the plan is
going on fire we're all [ __ ] done
it's [ __ ] yeah and the person the
lack of personal accountability when it
comes to the internet you should be able
to not watch [ __ ]
yeah like don't watch it if it's bad you
don't like your
feed that's your fault yep like real
talk
i have no problem with the algorithm i
think it's it makes
our life enjoyable whenever we pick up
our phone because
like it's showing me [ __ ] that i already
like i don't have to go searching for it
anymore
and now it's on you you have your own
accountability to put your phone down
exactly it's like if it's a kid if it's
happening to a kid it's the parents hey
you have to control their phone time and
get them
like to build that muscle of being able
to control it themselves and as an adult
you have no [ __ ] excuse
and also sorry go it's different though
young kids are like
that's all that quiets them down yeah
and laptop in the internet nah
that's it i'm not hearing that excuse me
i know it's tough to imagine a life of
kids
but not but it's interesting i see young
kids i see parents that
raise their children with no screen time
and they find things to do like i was
these little ass kids are like [ __ ]
playing soccer and they look like five
so it's like you can do other things go
the [ __ ] outside and do other stuff you
don't need to just sit them in front of
a screen it doesn't have to be two
extremes you can like let them use the
screen
and let them use the ipad and then also
take it away it's like we do that with
every single thing well i know we had to
have that done to us with video games
video games tv all that [ __ ] was just
gamified to try to keep you tuned in as
much as possible yeah they've just
kind of perfected the the system and
that's a little scary to us which i get
but it's been happening since you know
it's been happening for a minute
but there is something really important
that i hope people start to understand
it's like
teaching kids to have a certain
expectation and not even kids [ __ ]
adults
to have a certain expectation about the
information that they digest
you know what i mean like when we were
young we would go to the newspaper stand
with our pops or our moms right
you go to newspaper stand there'll be a
new york times there'll be washington
post there'll be daily news and there'll
be a national
choir right and you look at the national
choir you start reading it
and then your dad will be like oh that's
all [ __ ] that's fake don't trust
anything
so now in the future when i see a
headline for the national enquirer i'm
going oh that's [ __ ]
i'm not gonna trust that yeah right now
i'm not saying it can't be right but my
pop set of expectation
for what is right or wrong and if you're
on the internet you gotta tell your kids
the same [ __ ] and tell our [ __ ]
old-ass parents the same thing just
because you see a video with a ticker at
the bottom don't mean it's a legit new
source
yeah you know what i mean my mom out
here sending me 5g conspiracies and i
got to explain what the [ __ ] 5g
you on 3g you got the old iphone you got
two more g's you don't gotta worry
so now the only scary part is like the
generation that falls right
under that so the ones that are old
enough that they get
tricked by this [ __ ] yup and then they
have little kids who are impressionable
by the parents who are raising them yes
because now there's no filter yeah
exactly now the kids are consuming
everything that parents are consuming
they're believing that now you've got a
dad who believes in national inquiry
yes 100 don't get me wrong there is a
problem and we will find solutions for
it but the idea that this documentary
was pushing forward was essentially like
we got to stop the algorithm the
algorithm has already gone too far
this at the end it's like that same
algorithm is teaching
me everything i know about like the
world i want to research philosophers
i look it up on youtube i check it out i
want to learn about like boxers i want
to learn about like fights
everything i'm getting you know what
else is interesting who released this
documentary
netflix what does netflix use constantly
to get you to watch this
[Applause]
algorithm
you